[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter Lavelle
do you believe in miracles would seem
Democrats do after the Joe Biden surge
on Super Tuesday for them the fear of
the Bernie Sanders candidacy may now be
contained however this is far from over
taking on Trump will be no easy task
[Music]
Krauss sucking the war on Bernie I'm
joined by my guess Rania Khalek
in Beirut she is a producer and host at
in the now in New York we have lionel he
is illegal in media analyst also in New
York we have Danny - he is a
contributing editor at black agenda
report and co-author of American
exceptionalism and American innocence of
people's history of fake news from the
Revolutionary War to the war on terror
all right crosstalk rules in effect that
means you can jump in any time you want
and I always appreciate it
let's go to Beirut first Rania I feel
like after Super Tuesday looking at the
corporate media that you know there's a
whole lot of gas lighting going on it's
already a foregone conclusion Bernie's
out here and James Carville says he
should step a step down and leave the
campaign but you know for a very long
time Joe Biden had that position but no
one said that he should step down I
really think this gaslighting really
shows a lot of collusion between the DNC
and the media to frame the narrative
because Joe Biden hasn't changed okay
he's the same guy but the perception of
him is being radically altered and it's
being done intentionally and it's being
done at Bernie's expense go ahead and
Bay Road a hundred percent and you know
that narrative started after South
Carolina where you had the entire
establishment as well as the mainstream
media really changed the whole game in
favor of Joe Biden they gave him like
over seventy million dollars of
basically free positive publicity
framing him as the best candidate and
that really is the reason I think he did
so well because if you look at the polls
between a week ago and then Super
Tuesday
they were drastically different Joe
Biden got a huge bump from the media
portraying him as like the winner of the
whole primary after South Carolina a lot
of people didn't even choose who they
were gonna vote for until two or three
days before Super Tuesday so that helped
Joe Biden immensely plus you had the
entire Democratic establishment openly
in our faces coordinating with other
candidates to drop out to benefit Joe
Biden which did happen right Pete Buddha
judge dropping out was an in
coordination
the Democratic Party to help Joe Biden
save with Amy Klobuchar and you also
have Elizabeth Warren staying in the
race as it's more to try to obstruct
Sanders exactly that's exactly what she
did Joe Biden wasn't supposed to win in
the northern states the only reason he
did is because Elizabeth Warren took a
chunk of support away from Bernie
Sanders progressive based that a lot of
Warren reporters would have gone to
Sanders he probably would have won
Massachusetts in Minnesota okay she not
stayed in the race I mean let's go to
Lionel right now Lionel you must be
eating a whole lot of popcorn these days
watching this because I mean over the
last few days the number of gaffes that
Biden is committed I mean it's it's
embarrassing to watch but you'd never
see those gaps on CNN and MSNBC you see
a lot of it on Fox on the Internet
but I mean this is a like Pete Buddha
judge it was a manufactured candidate
Joe Biden is now an avatar for the DNC
go ahead Lionel
my dear dear friend Peter nobody cares
about the gaps nobody cares about the
malaprop's nobody nobody cares about
this you are my friend as am i proud as
that we are denizens of the bubble we
are in the set alone we talked to our
friend we said can you believe how he
confused his wife with his sister do you
know what the DNC is saying it doesn't
matter he is the candidate he is going
to be the candidate in July and that's
it and you know what as long as you keep
mentioning him doesn't matter
promise okay July actually I'm gonna
date myself it reminds me of being there
with Peter Sellers you know we have
Chauncey Gardiner running for the
Democrats right now okay look it up
everybody it's a good as good comparison
like to watch I like to watch it Danny
to watch Jani let me go to you in New
York I'll give my theses were up and
front here is that the dev the DNC knows
this presidential race is lost and
that's why they want Biden because if
Bernie were to get the nomination he
could change the way the Democratic
Party is governed out the DNC the
clintonites and and
and they want to keep everything the way
it is they would rather lose to Donald
Trump with a Biden than take a chance on
Bernie Sanders that's my theory
go ahead Danny we have to remember to in
exactly what you're saying in September
2019 huge corporate Democratic Party
donors threatened the DNC with our
thrall of huge donations to it's it's
institution just because Elizabeth
Warren was being considered as the
primary pick Elizabeth Warren has fallen
far from grace ever since but Bernie
Sanders represents a far more
existential threat to the DNC and The
Wall Street interest the
military-industrial complex and the rest
of them the blob so to speak and so this
was always a foregone conclusion the
attempt to rig the election against
Bernie Sanders we saw it in 2016 and we
saw it at the very beginning of the
20/20 campaign where it seemed like the
DNC was trying to find anyone anyone
they could find to take away votes to
split the electorate it didn't end up
working and so at the very last minute
after Nevada the DNC decided it's time
to get behind Biden the person who can
be most relied upon with his decades of
experience shilling for Wall Street
shilling for the mass incarceration
regime shilling for the intelligence
apparatus he will carry forward the
agenda of the ruling elite and he can be
most trusted to do that regardless of
the gaffes regardless of the
embarrassments that he may cause the
party what really matters is not beating
Trump it's an it's ensuring that the
rich stay rich and the rest of us suffer
you know it's go back to I think it's
really interesting it's very interesting
is that when you consider the money that
Mike Bloomberg pumped into it a half a
billion dollars all these content
consultants and media and all that I
mean he gave a lot of money to some very
very bad people that will keep this
business model going and that's exactly
what this is about they want to keep the
status quo going they don't it's not
about democracy not about what people
want it's what they want their interest
their careers and even being in
opposition is a good gig for them
they're doing great under Trump go ahead
and Beirut yeah as an
position the DNC has brought in tons of
money and what Danny was saying was a
hundred percent right by the way about
the DNC and the Democratic establishment
has more to lose from BER for under
Bernie Sanders and they do from letting
Trump win a second term and you know
let's not get this wrong I'm sure they
have no illusions that Joe Biden is a
terrible candidate to go up against
Trump and probably won't win they don't
care at the end of the day Trump is more
in Trump serves the class interests of
the Democratic establishment way more
than Bernie Sanders ever could Bernie
Sanders actually challenges it and
that's why they're fine with another
Trump presidency and like you said
they've had a great three years being in
the opposition it's so easy to be in the
opposition you can reel and money you
know support us every time Trump does
something bad without actually doing
anything to challenge any of the
policies that Trump is pushing or
putting into place they don't actually
do anything it's all just symbolic Nancy
Pelosi hand-clapping you know to make
everybody think we're the big opposition
well actually approving almost all of
trumps legislative agenda at the end of
the day they are more threatened by
Bernie Sanders than they are by Donald
Trump so they're happy they're perfectly
fine with another Trump presidency but
you know what that's gonna be a disaster
not just for her Americans but for the
rest of the world but they're just kind
of willing to sacrifice everybody so
that they can keep living large while
life sucks for everybody else okay let
me go back to Lionel in New York I mean
you know ever since the very beginning I
mean it was a Hillary Clinton that said
that Trump didn't have the temperament
to be President he wasn't presidential
and all that but last few days on the
stump I mean Trump really looks super
presidential against Joe Biden I mean
just the optics of it all go ahead
Lionel let me tell you what's happening
right now let me let me do this right
now hello Bernie yeah listen I love the
whole Democratic Socialist comedy thing
you did loved it do me a favor you're
gonna be out we'll give you a
seven-figure book deal like the last
ambassador to Ukraine your fourth or
fifth lakehouse a job for your wife and
your family and
that's it thanks a million now am-scray
and that is it let me tell you something
Donald Trump is the greatest president
of my lifetime and if anybody thinks
that any of these Democratic clowns any
of them could have done 10 percent of
what he's done for this country and the
world it's a delusion let me try to make
it even simpler the Democratic Party
this iteration is dead moraband
through pipe dream forget it it's over
you had nothing yet never ever even came
close to identifying and connecting with
mr. and mrs. American you want to do
this Greta tunberg climate change crap
what was your message what was Bernie's
message what was all of their message
I'll tell you what it was
I'm not Trump and as we say in the South
that dog don't hunt so guess what it was
your chance and you blew it okay okay
everyone's getting there a bit of steam
under the years here okay our other two
guests are not big fans of Donald Trump
so let's stay focused on the Democratic
Party here Danny I would never guess
it's all right it's all right
one minute Danny before we go to the
break here this is what they're doing
with joe and bernie is dividing the
party irreparably go ahead Danny one
minute before we go to the break
yes that's what exactly is happening and
we have to look at this as who is
benefiting and who won't benefit from
the destruction of the Democratic Party
I see the moribund Democratic Party as
being in need of replacement so what
really needs to happen is that Bernie
Sanders and this conflict between the
establishment will hopefully drive
enough energy of ordinary people to
begin to think about other alternatives
because yes the Democratic Party
establishment will do anything to
destroy Bernie Sanders and that will a
lien ate a lot of the base that the
Democratic Party needs to win okay
we're gonna go to a short break and
after that short break we'll continue
what is
session on the war on Bernie stay with
our team welcome back to crosswalk where
all things are considered I'm Peter
LaBelle to remind you were discussing
the war on Bernie
[Music]
okay let's go back to Beirut what I
think is very interesting here is what
some of the things that Danny were
saying because you know we all know that
the primaries of the is the silly season
that's what we call it for a good reason
but you know traditionally the party
comes together okay and you start
papering over the differences I don't
think that's gonna happen this time I
cannot see condi know a lot of Bernie
bros and they're excellent people really
nice people and really well-educated
people and and they and they we have I
have differences with them over policy
as I'm a conservative but I have a lot
of respect for him okay for a lot of
them that I've met they're not going to
vote for Joe Biden no way they're gonna
stay home what do you think go ahead in
Beirut I mean I think it's a mixed bag I
think some will and a lot won't there's
no telling like what the breakdown will
be but I don't think that Joe Biden will
have the sort of enthusiasm that he
needs
even without the Bernie bros or the
Bernie supporters but even you know
there might be like let's say there's
gonna be a significant number of people
that after this this entire nominating
process is finished and it's completely
clear that it's been stacked against
Bernie Sanders and they end up giving it
to Joe Biden there's gonna be a lot of
people who are irreparably alienated
from the Democratic Party and will never
want to do anything as a Democrat ever
again the Democratic Party is going to
lose a big chunk of support and that's
gonna make it very very difficult for
them to win an election against somebody
who has a huge support base Donald Trump
that's very committed and that will come
out and vote for him so I think this is
definitely gonna hurt them in the
election and long term it's gonna hurt
them as a party but I don't think they
care I think they're willing to blow up
their party if it means keeping things
the way that they are where you have a
bunch of elites controlling everything
and making a ton of money off of it yep
because they have no moral compass okay
it's been demonstrated over and over
again here let's go to Lionel you know
you know I know how you feel about
Donald Trump but the interesting thing
for me in looking at this rivalry inside
of the Democratic Party
it took Trump to take they did to
basically destroy the legacy of
took down Hillary Clinton and because
the Democrats can't get themselves in
order and actually present a platform to
run on because they're not they're just
demonizing one candidate and propping up
another that has nothing to do with
policy Trump indirectly and now he can
chalk up destroying the Democratic Party
and it's their own damned fault
go ahead Lionel well you know Peter
let's go back to when I was a kid and by
the way I am NOT a conservative or a
liberal or a Republican or even a
Democrat I I don't even know what those
terms mean but there was a time Peter
and you may remember this when the
Democrats stood for something anti-war
human rights gay rights civil rights you
name it they were industry they stood
for something I could check off what
their platforms worth now it's just
breathtakingly incoherent blather I
don't know what they're talking about
say what you want about Donald Trump
like him don't like him it doesn't
matter
nobody has ever scratched her head and
said what is this guy about what
programs does he what exactly is he
offering me and promising me for some
particular reason I haven't left the
Democrats they've left me this isn't
progressive thinking this isn't liberal
and the sad part is a young people today
believe this crap stands for something
it's psychobabble that's the problem you
know it's go to Danny here I mean I
actually was quite liberal a good part
of my life but I agree with Lionel um in
that point is that they left me okay
they don't talk to me they're not
interested in my problems as a matter of
fact I am the problem of according to a
lot of people in the Democratic Party
that is such you know they talk about
diversity and inclusion but what they do
is they push people out they pushed a
lot of people out here you know Danny
explained to me why the Democrats think
Hillary 2.0 is going to win this time
round and Joe is even weaker than
Hillary Clinton because Joe can't even a
string a few sentences together I mean
what are they smoking what are they
thinking about here I mean
there's no joke he says he is he's a
senior citizen you know this is this is
cruelty they said and I say this with a
straight face
i-i've by all accounts he's a nice guy
okay but if he can't figure out who his
wife is and his sister is does he belong
in the Oval Office
go ahead Danny well what you're saying
is exactly right and there's a huge
political problem presented by Joe
Biden's and confidence and his shady
policy record we have to understand
right now that the Democratic Party is
in full overdrive in hiding and
concealing the past 40 years of
neoliberal degradation endless war and
the assault on working people that it
has been totally complicit in and this
need to hide that policy agenda which
has ultimately been a highlight of Joe
Biden's entire campaign no one seems to
want to really go at him for what he has
actually done in his long illustrious
career serving the establishment when
what is really going to be a problem for
him against Donald Trump is that you
don't have to as Lionel said you don't
have to look very far to know what Trump
stands for and also what he's done he
can go to the left against Joe Biden on
issues of war and peace he can say that
he signed a peace deal with the Taliban
he can say that he's always been for
removing troops from Syria regardless of
whether it happens or not and then he
can move to his right and actually
appeal to his base who he needs to
appeal to on issues of immigration in
the economy while Joe Biden will have to
spend over time hiding his policy agenda
from the Democratic Party base which
sees Medicare for all agree New Deal all
these things as beneficial policies in
the vast majority we're talking about 80
percent want agree New Deal 58 percent
want Medicare fro that's what he's going
to have to hide from it good look so the
Democratic Party establishment doesn't
care
Danny but you said I think twice or
three times he's gonna have to go into
overdrive he's his time is up okay he
can't go into overdrive okay it's
myself already okay let's go back to
Beirut here okay you know but one of the
things you know when I'm watching this
whole saga the spectacle play out you
know and when you look at the entire
what I think was twenty four candidates
and at one point you know and again you
know that the identitarian politics the
diversity and all of this they end up
with a seventy year old white man what
happened here okay what happened here I
mean I mean the only thing that Joe
Biden has ever excelled at is being
mediocre go ahead and be rude well I
mean I don't think it's necessarily
about whether they ended up with a white
78 year old man I mean that would have
also been Bernie Sanders it's not so
much about that it's so much the
politics it's more about the policies
that Joe Biden represents you do have
this new sort of woke identity politics
that the Democratic you know neoliberal
establishment has embraced in a very
superficial way and so it's not about
the fact that Joe Biden's an old white
man it's about the policies he's
supported throughout his career whether
it's the crime bill and pushing that
whether it's literally whipping
Democratic votes for the war in Iraq the
most destructive foreign policy decision
of the 21st century or you know whether
it's opposing busing and basically like
you know befriending segregationists
back in the day and also you know it's
just and that's what's so shocking about
this is Joe Biden's entire record is the
opposite of all of these superficial
woke identity politics slogans that the
Democrats have been you know throwing
around for the past five or six years
okay Lionel you want to jump in there go
ahead you know Peter there's something
I've got to say two things first to you
my good friend and my new friends here
there's something about Bernie Sanders
that I like he's a rebel he has been
Bernie Sanders for thirty plus years
what you see is what you get this is
what he said he's authentic he believes
in whether he's right or whether there's
something to be said for that
agreed number two
I feel so sorry for yet again young
people who put their money and their
time and their effort and their belief
in somebody only to have it pulled away
and let me tell you you know who's gonna
be the person responsible for the
ultimate double-cross Bernie because he
never had it in his mind at all to take
this all the way and that's the sad part
because I'm telling you as much as he
may be antithetical to me politically or
ideologically there's something about
him that I'd like damn it he stands for
something and that's refreshing you know
and Danny one of the things I guess ever
since Super Tuesday actually even before
it I mean in my small circle that I talk
on a very regular basis about politics
there's one theme and most of my friends
are conservative but most people are
almost all conservatives I know watch
Bernie very closely it's very
interesting
why doesn't he fight back why doesn't he
take a punch it's politics after all I
think a lot of it has to do with the
fact that in electoral politics
especially the Democratic Party at this
time so-called bourgeois civility this
idea that you cannot challenge the
establishment you can't challenge the
way things work in the DNC but you can
challenge the policies all of that has
to do with why Bernie Sanders doesn't
challenge the Democratic Party
establishment head-on he does so in the
way he organizes his campaign he does so
in the way that he stands for things
like Medicare for all in a green new
deal but he does not go up against the
DNC establishment I'm guessing some of
that has to do with fear some of that
has to do also with the fact that he
wants to run within the Democratic Party
establishment he wants to win an
election within the Democratic Party and
in order to do so you have to kiss the
ring of the DNC and how the DNC does
things now I think that's a monumental
mistake on Bernie Sanders this part
especially after he was attacked with
the Russia Gate farce when they tried to
say The Washington Post and the FBI CIA
they tried to say that Russia was trying
to help him when he went along with that
I think
was one of the first steps of Bernie
Sanders looking weak in front of the
Democratic Party establishment you know
it's very interest go back to Beirut I I
saw that in a way with with Bloomberg
what a fumble what an unforced error
that Bernie committed right there I was
I was astounded by here's a policy wonk
guy that can tell you all kinds of
things about everything I mean he's been
in politics for so long and then he
fumbles a fundamental thing that will
stick to him let's go back to Beirut
last 40 seconds here is is Bernie gonna
keep fighting or is he's gonna let the
media destroy him go ahead Beirut I
think Bernie in the movement he build
are gonna keep fighting I just don't
know if they can win I'm a generally
cynical person so I've kind of been
cynical about the process from the
beginning I didn't think they were gonna
let Bernie win regardless and I still
think that's the case the question is
what do we do about it what do we do
about it
do we do what happened in 2016 where
everybody just gets behind the nominee
because that's what happened and I think
that was a mistake and Trump still won
or do we do something different people
need to start having that conversation
and unfortunately I don't see that
happening okay long the movement around
Bernie Sanders yeah the problem is the
problem is is that the Democrats have to
start reimagining politics but they seem
completely incapable of doing it that's
all the time we have many thanks and I
guess in New York and in Beirut and
thanks to our viewers for watching us
here at RT see you next time and
remember Rostock rules
[Music]